estamos en medio de la noche y un ave
rapaz nocturna quizá este es un búho
está a punto de ir por su cena y este
que tenemos aquí es un ratón un ratón y
está clavándose en línea recta cerca de
un farol veamos que información tenemos
para este problema el farol que tenemos
aquí tiene una altura de 20 pies 20 pies
es entonces la altura de este farol y en
este preciso momento aunque mi dibujo
nuestra escala el búho se encuentra
directamente arriba del ratón a una
altura de 15 pies
el búho se encuentra a 15 pies por
encima del ratón y el ratón se encuentra
déjame indicar esto a 10 pies de la base
del farol a 10 pies de la base del farol
y también sabemos tenemos un radar
puesto que en este momento el búho
en picada hacia el ratón a una velocidad
de 20 pies por segundo así que en este
momento el búho baja a 20 pies por
segundo ahora lo que nos interesa es que
el farol emite la luz en todas
direcciones al emitir la luz hacia todos
lados proyecta la sombra del búho que se
encuentra aquí de tal manera que cuando
el búho va en picada su sombra va a ir
moviéndose hacia la izquierda entonces
la pregunta es dado todo esto que
tenemos aquí a qué razón se está
moviendo la sombra veamos entonces que
conocemos y que no conocemos y para esto
fijemos algunas variables déjame dibujar
esto de aquí un poquito más
geométricamente entonces aquí tenemos el
farol
de altura 20 pies luego por aquí tenemos
la altura a la que se encuentra el búho
sobre el ratón la altura en la que se
encuentra el búho que es de 15 pies esta
que tenemos aquí representa la distancia
del ratón al farol que es de 10 pies y
para ubicar la sombra
pensemos en esta luz que se emite en
todas las direcciones aquí es bloqueada
por el wall para proyectar la sombra
hacia el piso así es que si dibujamos
una línea recta de la fuente de luz que
pasa por el búho y llega al piso ahí
ubicaremos la sombra aquí la tenemos
entonces una línea recta que representa
el rayo de luz pasa por el búho llega al
piso y aquí está la sombra
ahí está la sombra y tenemos que
calcular qué tan rápido qué tan rápido
se está moviendo esa sombra hacia la
izquierda establezcamos entonces algunas
variables por aquí que sabemos bueno la
altura del búho está cambiando la altura
algo está cambiando
llamémosle y en estos momentos es 15
pero es una variable que está cambiando
y a la distancia entre la sombra y el
ratón
que también está cambiando vamos a
llamarle x x va a designar la distancia
entre la sombra y el ratón ahora a
partir de esta figura que tenemos aquí
queremos establecer una relación entre
xy lo que queremos obtener al final de
cuentas es cuál es la razón a la que
cambia x con respecto al tiempo
conocemos y también conocemos de i ended
y así una vez que tengamos la relación
la vamos a derivar con respecto al
tiempo para obtener al final de cuentas
de x en de t para cualquier instante de
tiempo bueno estos dos triángulos que
tenemos aquí déjame marcarlos para que
quede claro cuáles son los dos
triángulos este pequeño triángulo que
estoy dibujando en verde este pequeño
triángulo es semejante a este otro
triángulo más grande este que estoy
dibujando en azul estos dos son
triángulos semejantes y como sé que son
triángulos semejantes bueno aquí tenemos
un ángulo recto en ambos tenemos un
ángulo recto este ángulo lo tienen como
por lo cual tienen tres ángulos iguales
este ángulo tiene que ser igual a éste
así que estos triángulos son semejantes
lo cual implica que la razón que se
tiene entre lados correspondientes
debe ser idéntica por lo que entonces la
razón de x allí la razón de x allí tiene
que ser igual a la razón de esta base
del triángulo mayor que es x más 10 a la
altura del triángulo mayor que es igual
a 20 y aquí tenemos una relación entre
xy y si tomamos la derivada con respecto
al tiempo obtendremos lo que estamos
buscando pero antes de que obtengamos la
derivada con respecto al tiempo lo
podríamos hacer pero es mejor
simplificar así que hagamos la
multiplicación cruzada de los
denominadores para simplificar esta
expresión multiplicamos entonces ambos
lados por 20 y para deshacernos de los
denominadores entonces del lado
izquierdo la aie se simplifica y nos
resulta 20 x esto va a ser igual y del
lado izquierdo nos queda perdón del lado
izquierdo que da 20 x y del lado derecho
resulta 20 y 20 se simplifica
y queda x más 10 x + 10 y ya puedo
derivar ambos lados con respecto al
tiempo del lado izquierdo que tenemos la
derivada de 20 algo con respecto al
tiempo es la derivada de 20 algo con
respecto a algo la ayuda de 20 x con
respecto a x es 20 por la derivada de x
con respecto al tiempo que es de x en dt
y del lado derecho que tenemos aquí
vamos a tener que aplicar la regla el
producto va a ser la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo va a ser de x en dt x
qué
más x por la derivada de con respecto al
tiempo que es simplemente dejé en de t
más
la derivada de 17 con respecto a la
ayuda de 10 con respecto a tener la
ayuda de 10 con respecto a ley que es 10
por la derivada de ye con respecto a t
que es simplemente deje en dt y ya lo
tenemos ya tenemos una relación entre de
x dt de jane de x y veamos si tenemos
todo lo que necesitamos está de aquí de
x en dt es lo que queremos encontrar por
aquí también lo tenemos esto lo que
estamos buscando está ya la conocemos y
dejen de 'the legend dt aquí la tenemos
y por convención como la distancia se
está cortando ésta sería menos 20
conocemos de jane de t
entonces aquí también tenemos otro de
jane de t
si conocemos el valor de x podemos
encontrar entonces cuánto vale x en ese
momento bueno vamos a encontrarlo de
esta expresión podemos encontrarlo aquí
pero ésta está más simplificada así es
que nos va a ser más fácil encontrar el
valor de x para después encontrar de x
en dt en esta expresión calculemos lo
por aquí sería 20 x
va a ser igual a equis porque que en
este momento vale 15 x por 15 más
recordemos podemos haberlo calculado de
la expresión anterior pero es mucho más
fácil en esta que tenemos aquí abajo
entonces x por 15 más 10
10 x 15 entonces deja de ver si lo hice
bien 20 x 15 x 10 x 15 10 x 15 si está
correcto entonces que tenemos aquí 20 x
es igual a 15 x más 150 restándole 15 x
ambos lados nos resulta 5 x del lado
izquierdo es igual a 30 no no no estoy
adelantando me 5 x es igual a 150 con lo
cual x es igual a 30 x es igual a 30
pies en ese momento el valor de x es 30
pies
entonces regresando en nuestro diagrama
original esta distancia de aquí es igual
a 30 pies
sustituyamos entonces los valores en
esta expresión para encontrar el valor
de the x en dt entonces que tenemos no
va a ser por acá tenemos 20 que
multiplica
de x ende te lo voy a poner en rosa de x
en dt y esto es igual a de x en dt
que multiplica a 10 y que vale 15 pies
entonces de x en dt por no no me gusta
ese color por 15 más el valor de x que
vimos que es igual a 30% de 'the legend
de test de yens dt es igual a menos 20
el búho trabajando en ese momento en ese
momento el búho está bajando por su cena
por lo cual de jane dt es igual a menos
20 entonces 30 por menos 20 más
degen de 10 x 20 pies por segundo
despejemos entonces de x el dt que
tenemos 20 de x en dt no mejor mira voy
a restar 15 de x en dt de ambos lados
entonces del lado izquierdo me quedaría
5 de x en de t 20 menos 15 es igual a 5
de x en dt eso queda del lado izquierdo
esto va a ser igual a aquí que tenemos
30 x menos 20 30 x menos 20 es igual a
menos 600 y este otro término es 10 x
menos 20 que es igual a menos 200 menos
600 más menos 200 es igual a menos 800
pies por segundo
de hecho si esto va a estar en pies por
segundo dividiendo ambos lados entre 5
que tenemos de x en de te va a ser igual
5 por 16 es igual 80 así de x tendentes
igual a menos 160 pies por segundo y
hemos terminado
hemos encontrado entonces que las
sombras se están moviendo a una
velocidad muy muy grande
sombra se está moviendo hacia la
izquierda x está disminuyendo aquí
tenemos el signo negativo las sombras se
están moviendo hacia la izquierda se
está acercando al ratón a una velocidad
sorprendente